poor parents they go to a school board
meeting they speak out about
age-appropriate material being taught
their kids and they of course are going
to be investigated anyway let's get to
the bottom of that now also tonight well
Democrats are freaking out over Twitter
well many are ignoring the true threat
that is posed by Tick Tock now keep in
mind Tick Tock is a chinese-owned app
that poses a real serious security
threat to the people around the world
now two years ago then president Trump
he attempted to ban Tick Tock citing
spyware concerns and he warned the
American people against downloading the
app now even one top Democrat is
admitting president Trump was was right
about this from the get-go take a look
look it can't be controlled for security
reasons by China too big too
invasive and it can't be I think Donald
Trump was right I mean Tick Tock is a
enormous threat
with reaction someone who just banned
Tick Tock from State agencies South
Dakota Governor Christie gnomes with us
Governor good to see you thank you um
tell us exactly what you're Banning and
who is
uh part of the band in the sense All
State agencies any contractors right
yes Sean yesterday I signed an executive
order that would ban downloading The
Tick Tock app or accessing it at all
from any state device it's off our
networks it's blocked off of our servers
any state employee anybody who contracts
with the state of South Dakota anybody
who uses any of our systems no longer
will be able to download or utilize this
app because of the national security
threat that it is it will be a criminal
offense if they do because of the threat
and the access to personal information
that it would jeopardize so it's
important that we take action to protect
the people of South Dakota you're
talking a lot tonight about Twitter and
what Elon Musk is uncovering with
Twitter that's an American-owned company
you look at what how they have
manipulated algorithms and think about
how China has manipulated the algorithms
to spy on the American people and
collect data off of them it's so much
worse and there are enemy they hate us
this is why it's so important that other
elected officials take action as well
he said that South Dakota will have no
part in the intelligence gathering
operations of Nations that hate us you
said the Chinese Communist party is
using the information that it's
Gathering From Tick Tock to manipulate
the American people and gather data of
their devices that access their platform
my question is how do we know that's
true and how deep does it go for example
if somebody would have sent me a tick
tock and I click on it I don't have it
on my phone would they have access to
information on my my phone right now
because I click did a click on it
we are uncovering more and more all the
time that yes they are using that data
that they are using and even could
possibly be able to go back and utilize
what buttons you pushed on your phone
your passwords you use to access your
bank accounts all of that information
the Chinese government the CCP is
collecting and using uh to spy on the
American people to manipulate their
algorithms to gather information about
us because they hate us and they have a
long-term agenda to destroy the United
States of America listen we know the
threat that China has been for decades
and decades they've manipulated their
currency stolen our IP built up their
military threatened us and and attacked
our allies we know what their agenda is
we have to recognize that they're using
this app to gather more and more
information from American citizens that
they can use to harm us in the future
now we've known about their unfair Trade
Practices and intellectual property
thefts when it comes to the Chinese
Governor maybe you can explain this to
me because it doesn't make any sense to
me we have discovered that the Communist
Chinese through different llc's
different groups that they have been
buying up American farmland and American
Ranch Land and often they're buying it
next to locations that have military
installations now we would not be
allowed to buy a bland in China my
question is why are we allowing that to
happen here and doesn't it seem
suspicious that often the case it's next
to the military base
yeah you're exactly right they have and
they have a goal to buy up our food
supply chain to buy up land that could
threaten our military bases threaten our
able our ability to defend ourselves
listen I've talked about this for about
20 years Sean just because I've been
involved in food policy but we saw China
come in buy up our Manufacturing Systems
our fertilizer companies our chemical
companies they're slowly buying up our
entire food supply chain and when we
don't control our food supply when
another country does that's when they
control Us by purchasing land they're
Gathering more and more control over us
we have a state law in South Dakota that
bans them from buying any foreign entity
actually from buying more than 150 acres
we're going to be addressing that again
in January though in our legislative
session because I don't believe we
should allow them to purchase any land
or have long-term leases because of the
threat that they face they threaten the
United States you're describing a real
National security threat why isn't Joe
Biden leading the effort and banning it
nationwide
he's not leading on anything Sean I mean
that's the that's the real problem we
have in America today our president
doesn't know today's Wednesday weak and
non-existent I mean
he probably does you know that's the
challenge that we have so honestly this
President
um is AWOL and we've got to find a
strong leader to defend this country and
you can't just focus on one thing you
have to focus on so many threats that we
face it's not just China it's Iran it's
Russia it's our energy Supply they are
trying to weaken the United States of
America by coming after us on the things
that every single family in this country
needs to get through a day and and
that's why we need to have better
leadership and why Joe Biden is such a
freaking disaster
yeah well Governor thanks for being with
us thanks for what you're doing I hope
other Governors follow as well it would
be nice if Biden and the administration
did but I'm not holding my breath hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else